foreign
welcome back to CBS mornings and welcome
back to some new reporting in our
investigation into how the military
handles veterans who were discharged
because they are gay or lesbian from
World War II to the repeal of don't ask
don't tell in 2011 an estimated 100 000
service members were discharged because
of their sexuality and they often
received a less than honorable discharge
which can seriously hurt a veterans
benefits and job opportunities CBS News
Chief investigative correspondent Jim
Axelrod spoke to a veteran who's fought
for years to upgrade their discharge
good morning Jim Good morning Tony the
woman that we are about to meet has a
story that raises many questions at the
top of the list why does the Pentagon
continue to drag its feet in correcting
an injustice suffered by so many
veterans simply due to their sexuality
especially when the policy that allowed
for the Discrimination was repealed more
than a dozen years ago
I'm trying to be strong and it's like I
can't talk about
my past Elaine Rodriguez's Story begins
just 10 months after she graduated from
Navy boot camp in 1989. that's your dad
look at his smile he's proud oh yeah
proud of his daughter yeah the pride she
felt that day evaporated when confronted
by a naval investigator asking her about
her sexuality did he straight up ask you
are you gay yes how do you handle that
the best way I could I just
denied it in the pre don't ask don't
tell Witch Hunt days Elaine's initial
denial only intensified the
investigation they don't really question
me they tell me everything about my life
I had a civilian girlfriend at the time
they told me her name they told me the
apartment complex she lived in they told
me the bar we used to go to that's when
I just threw my hands up in the air and
I just said you know what
yes it's all true she was given an other
than honorable discharge her DD214 the
discharge document cites misconduct
Commission of a serious offense as the
reason that one line on your DD214
really still does a number on you it
makes me feel like I'm a criminal
I lied about my sexuality the career
Elaine envisioned was over before it
started she lost all her benefits and
was shut out of a new dream I can't be a
police officer like I wanted to
because of my DD214 yeah they messed up
my life
cases like Elaine Rodriguez's these
aren't isolated cases are they no
they're not isolated at all Senator
Kirsten gillibrand who successfully
fought to get don't ask don't tell
repealed in 2010. this is a policy that
is corrosive is frustrated that more
than 12 years later the Pentagon still
hasn't made it right for thousands of
gay vets why are these vets still having
to fight for discharges they deserve and
benefits that they've earned because the
dod has been fighting us every step of
the way is this a case of bureaucratic
inertia
or is this lingering homophobia I'm not
sure but I wouldn't be surprised if it
was the latter because if they wanted
this done it would be done and there's
still so many veterans who don't even
know they can ask for an upgrade
that's really disturbing Christy bagalow
runs a non-profit that helps all
veterans seeking discharge upgrades of
the more than 1200 inquiries she gets
each month less than one percent are
from lgbtq vets that's what worries me I
know they're out there the Pentagon told
CBS News there's an easy two-page
application veterans can fill out I
don't recommend that you're very
unlikely to get an upgrade based on a
two-page form bagalow says vets have
less than a one in three chance of a
discharge upgrade when applying without
a lawyer a problem she feels is the
pentagons to fix the burden is
completely on the veteran to prove to
the boards that the military did
something wrong or that there was an
injustice I mean the men and women who
serve in our military are the bravest
and greatest in the world Senator
gillibrand has been pushing the defense
department to act for years
but she says ultimately Justice for
veterans like Elaine Rodriguez depends
on pressure from one place if you have a
champion in the White House it makes a
big difference so if this becomes
something that President Biden wants to
actually accomplish during his White
House it'll make it that much easier so
you must have felt like oh my goodness
this thing is going to follow me till
the end of my life oh yeah in 2017
Elaine got her discharge upgraded to
General
still not The Honorable she wants what
is the answer to that they said because
I lied and the language misconduct
Commission of a serious offense
that didn't change not very many people
know that I was in the military not very
many people even know
that
what happened to me
it hurts you'd made a choice to serve I
did
I made a choice for this country and
they didn't accept me because I'm gay
the Navy told us it would not comment on
Elaine Rodriguez's case citing privacy
guidelines but in 2017 when she applied
for that upgrade one member of the
review board
said that all the way before the initial
refusal to upgrade her that whole
decision had been done properly properly
properly so they upgraded her to a
general discharge but kept that that
damaging language on there about
misconduct but what was the reason they
couldn't go all the way to honorable
well Elaine says and and the key is that
phrase that you're pointing out the
military cited this making false
statements charges even though Elaine
said to them in a letter look I was
quote scared to death so long after
don't ask don't tell had been repealed
remember this has been six seven years
later long after the notion that
someone's sexuality should be used in
assessing their Fitness to serve Elaine
is still paying the price and still
under that Banner of her committing some
truly awful offense yeah and as senator
gillibrand says if the military wants it
done
it could get done all right that's true
I guess this on the steps of the White
House now we'll see Jim Axelrod
brilliant report